well I think most actors recognize that
you know you're being cast to type
you're being cast people are getting you
and because they think you're close to
that character you know so you're the
first thing you have to ask yourself is
okay if that's the case how much of my
self is part of this character they've
asked me to play so you start looking
into your own personality and see where
it matches up with the traits the
character have now you might have to
sort of sometimes push parts of you you
might have to kind of you know you may
not be as angry for example as a
character in normal life you may not be
as you know and naturally as happy as
the character isn't oh yeah so you have
to kind of put your gauge in there and
find out there and once you built in the
blocks of what it is in that character
is like you you can then start to look
outside the box now you know and in the
case of someone like Ted Hastings for
example obviously I was able to bring a
huge amount of my of my self to it you
know which was brilliant and then beyond
that then I was able to factor in
certain things for example you know we
decided that Ted was going to be
probably a Catholic within the RUC which
at that time meant that he was a very
tiny percentage of the force I mean
really tiny around maybe two or three
percent so it meant that he was an
insider an outsider a rather within a
force so that would we felt give him
leeway to when he transferred into the
UK he would still be an outsider but
would be used to kind of handling that
pressure of being an outsider within a
force and then beyond that then you've
got to look at what the big character
traits are for someone who's in a
position of authority
you know man management you look at Alex
Ferguson you know you look at Austin
beggar you're looking at people who can
man manage people you know and that's
usually you you look at football
managers for that because there are the
most obvious ones we have to deal with
personalities all the time those are the
sort of things that are going through
your head also physicality how would
their character
physically what's this delivery like and
then within the script of course the
likes you know so Jed materials written
the script so this clues all the clues
are in the script as to what the
person's attitude is to things all the
time so you're looking through the
script scripts I can't even know where
you find your little bits of Goldust and
then if you feel that there's something
coming through that you can push then
you can maybe suggest to the writer look
let's do a little bit of more of this
let him be a little bit more like that
and you know once the writer sees you
working as well they'll start to move
into those territories anyway and so it
becomes this kind of unconscious
collaboration between you and the writer
of course that's in TV and theater it's
a different thing a lot of the time you
can't you know chat to the writer
because he could be 300 years dead so
but it does work on TV well you have
access directly to the writer and don't
forget the relationship between the
actor and the writer is really clean you
know it's a two really good two-way
street everybody's trying to help each
other within that one it's a good one
well I think complexity is what I really
like you know I like to have a day's
work to do the end of it I feel like
I've done something so if its complexity
is good psychological you know the the
big you know carrying dramatic subtext
if you like I like that sort of thing I
like subtext you will work where people
are reading into what you're doing I
kind of you know trying to figure out
where they're at and so that's the kind
of thing I look for I look for a good
story I like it to have a point you know
it's nice of things have a have a point
and we kind of mature take on stuff that
I can get behind as a person so that
kind of thing really I read the scripts
immediately I didn't you know
immediately think this is gonna be a
huge hit or anything none of us really
kind of knew that a really interesting
new procedural type of police drama I
could see that from the get-go the
structure of it was really interesting
losing that was really new about it you
know when you see those elements come
along you think this this this has a
chance you know
but the writing was in particular you
know I thought was great writing you
know this great writer called Kurt
Vonnegut who once said that you know
we're all born into one family and then
you spend the rest of your life you know
running around finding out what's the
other family you belong to and you know
some of us get lucky you know and we
find the kind of this family that we all
belong to because we all got the shared
interest in the arts and in cinema and
in the TV and the theatre and you know
and I was lucky I found that place to
exist well I I think the best bit of
advice is that you should always make
sure that there's nothing that you're
doing that's getting in the way of you
progressing and that goes right across
the border so how you are you look you
know you've got to be pretty neutral as
an actor for people to kind of project
stuff onto you for example what your
attitude is you know all those small
things don't allow anything get in the
way of you reaching that person clear
all that stuff out of the way you know
keep my old mind and and just go for it
[Music]
[Music]
you